Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Initialement j'avais prévu de vous emmener au
musée voir les tableaux de William Turner.
Je suis sûr que vous connaissez ce peintre
anglais du début du XIXe siècle.
Il a peintdes ciels totalement embrasés, comme celui-ci.
Certains lui ont d'ailleurs reproché
d'avoir un peu trop abusé sur le rouge,
lacouleur hein ?
Eh bien non, il n'en a pas rajouté.
Lui comme tous ses contemporains a bienassisté
à un tel spectacle.
Et si le cielétait si rouge, c'est tout simplement
parcequ'à l'époque, il était voilé.
La lumière du soleil était masquée.
Je vais vous racontercette incroyable histoire.
Allez, au tableau.
Voici William Turner, quand il était jeune, le
peintre de la lumière.
Alors que les couleurs des paysages anglais tirent plutôt sur le bleu, le vert, le marron, Turner peint des ciels totalement enflammés
tirant parfois sur le rouge sang.
On a ditqu'il avait des problèmes de vue.
Pas du tout !
Les couleurs qu'il a couché sur la toile témoignent
d'un événement qui a bouleversé le climat
de la planète en 1815 et qui sans Turner et d'autres
peintres, aurait peut-être sombrer dans l'oubli
puisque personne n'en a parlé à l'époque :
leréveil du volcan Tambora.
Le Tambora est situé en Indonésie à 11 000 kilomètres de l'Angleterre.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un stratovolcan.
Il forme un cône au versant très pentu.
Un peu comme leVésuve près de Naples.
Le dôme est constitué de lave très visqueuse,
ce sont des volcans explosifs.
le 10 avril 1815, le Tambora entre en éruption.
Une pluie de roches s'abat sur l'île de Sumbava
tandis que des nuées ardentes, des avalanches de cendres et de poussières incandescentes, déferlentles pentes
ensevelissant et tuant au moins 10 000 personnes.
Avant l'éruption, le Tambora culminait à 4000 mètres d'altitude.
Il va perdre un tiers de sa hauteur.
On vous a racontél'histoire du Vésuve,
vous avez vu les films, des reconstitutions,
lors de l'éruption qui s'estdéroulé en 1979,
le volcan Italien a projeté six kilomètres cubes de matière dans l'atmosphère.
En1815, le Tambora en projette 100 kilomètres cubes,
seize fois plus.
Pendant les deux jours qui suiventl'éruption,
toute la région dans un rayon de 600 km est plongée dans l'obscurité,
des pluies de cendres
détruisent les récoltes et polluent les eaux.
Mais ce n'est pas tout. La colonne de cendres et
de poussières s'élève à 40 km d'altitude.
Pour mémoire, les avions ne circulent qu'à dix mille
mètres d'altitude.
100 mégas tonnes d'acide sulfurique se répandent autour de la planète
formant une sorte de voile qui va perdurer pendant 3 ans.
Cette pollution atmosphérique
arrête une partie du rayonnement solaire résultat:
la température diminue à la surface du globe et
des records de froid sont enregistrés.
-17 à Londres ! Oh my "gogogo" god !
Sur le vieux continent, l'année 1816 et baptisée "l'année sans été".
Privées de récoltes, soumises à climat froid et humide,
les populations rurales de France, de Suisse
d'Allemagne, d'Angleterre et d'Irlande subissent
de terribles famines entre 1816 et 1818.
Certains auteurs estiment que cette éruption a engendré
indirectement plusieurs centaines de milliers de morts.
Mais que viennent faire les rouges
flamboyants de Turner dans cette histoire.
Eh bien ils matérialisent la pollution qui
s'est répandue à la surface du globe
et qui a tout particulièrement affecté le ciel du nord
de l'Europe.
Les aérosols sulfurés qui composent ce voile ont la particularité de renvoyer
versl'espace les ondes les plus courtes,
celles qui correspondent aux couleurs bleues, indigos, vertes,
nelaissant passer que les plus longues.
Autrement dit, celles qui sont proches du rouge.
Si vousajoutez à ce phénomène, la diffusion du rouge
au lever et au coucher du soleil, dû à la distance
que parcourt la lumière dans l'atmosphère
à ces moments de la journée, eh bien vous obtenez un
rouge comme celui que Turner a peint.
Assez réaliste finalement.
A l'époque, personne en Europene sait ce qui est à l'origine de ces phénomènes.
Nul n'a entendu parler de l'éruption du Tambora.
Et quand bien même, qui aurait pu faire le lien avec le volcan.
La météorologie est balbutianteet la volcanologie n'existe pas
en tant que discipline scientifique.
On ne comprendra cetteanomalie climatique,
qui heureusement a laissé des traces sur le tableaux de Turner
que dans lesannées 1960 en analysant des carottes.
Des carottes ?!
Oui, des carottes glaciaires.
La glace se forme àpartir de précipitations.
De la neige qui renferme des particules présentes dans l'atmosphère del'époque.
Elle forme une sorte de millefeuille.
Plus on creuse, plus on remonte le temps,
plus ondécouvre le climat du passé.
C'est ainsi que les glaciologues ont observé une grande concentration
de particules volcaniques dans la glace
qui s'estformée aux alentours de 1815 et qu'ils ont
compris l'origine du refroidissement.
Allez,une dernière histoire.
Vous connaissez ce livre"Frankenstein" ?
Eh bien, sans l'éruption du Tambora, il n'aurait peut-être jamais vu le jour.
il aété écrit par Mary Shelley durant l'été 1816.
A l'époque, elle est en vacances en suisse.
LordByron, le célèbre poète anglais l'a invitée, elle et d'autres auteurs
à passer quelques jours dans sonchalet.
Mais le temps est tellement pourri
qu'il est impossible de mettre le nez dehors.
Pour passer letemps, Lord Byron lance un concours d'écriture.
C'est à celle ou celui qui écrira l'histoire la plus terrifiante.
Mary Shelley va l'emporter en imaginant sa créature fantastique.
Au passage,Frankenstein n'est pas le nom du monstre mais
le nom du médecin et qui lui a donné vie.
Pendantce temps, Lord Byron écrit une petite nouvelle
qu'il baptise : "Le Vampire".
C'est cette nouvellequi va inspirer 80 ans plus tard Bram Stocker,
l'auteur de Dracula.
Bon, je vais peut-être arrêterlà avec mes histoires qui font peur,
vous allez finir par ne plus avoir envie de me voir,
même enpeinture.
Allez, à bientôt.
Alors que les couleurs du...je reprends.
Ce qui est à l'origine de cesphénomènes... Dommage.
Ne laissant passer que les plus cons...
Je vais peut être tout reprendre.